[Music]
let me begin by observing first of all
that 9000 was the sum of years which had
elapsed since the war which was said to
have taken place between those who dwelt
outside to the pillars of Herakles and
all who dwelt within them of the
combatants on the one side the city of
Athens was reported to have been the
leader and 2a fought out the war the
combatants on the other side were
commanded by the kings of Atlantis which
as I was saying was an island greater in
extent than Libya and Asia and when
afterwards sunk by an earthquake became
an impassable barrier of mud to voyagers
sailing from hence to any part of the
ocean
[Music]
I have before a marked in speaking of
the allotments of the gods that they
distributed the whole earth in two
portions differing in extent and made
for themselves temples and instituted
sacrifices and Poseidon receiving for
his lot the island of Atlantis began
children by a mortal woman and settled
them in part of the island which I will
describe looking towards the sea but in
the center of the whole island there was
a plane which is said to have been the
fairest of all planes and very fertile
near the plane again and also in the
center of the island at a distance of
about 50 stadia there was a mountain not
very high on any side in this mountain
there dwelt one of the Earthborn
primeval man of that country whose name
was Evan or and he had a wife named Leah
CPA and they had an only daughter who
was called kholate oh the maiden had
already reached womanhood when her
father and mother died Poseidon fell in
love with her and had intercourse with
her and breaking the ground enclosed the
hill in which she dwelt all round making
alternate zones of sea and land larger
and smaller encircling one another there
were two of land and three of water
which he turned as with a lathe each
having its circumference equidistant
every way from the center so that no man
could get to the island for ships and
voyages were not as yet
[Music]
he himself being a God found no
difficulty in making special
arrangements for the center island
bringing up two Springs of water from
beneath the earth one of warm water and
the other of cold and making every
variety of food to spring up abundantly
from the soil he also began and brought
up five pairs of twin male children and
dividing the island of Atlantis into ten
portions he gave to the firstborn of the
eldest pair his mother's dwelling and
the surrounding allotment which was the
largest and best and made him king over
the rest the others he made princess and
gave them rule over many men and a large
territory and he named them all the
eldest who was the first king he named
atlas and after him the whole island and
the ocean were called Atlantic now Atlas
had a numerous and honorable family and
they retained the kingdom the eldest son
handing it on to his eldest son for many
generations and they had such an amount
of wealth as was never before possessed
by kings and is not likely ever to be
again and they were furnished with
everything which they needed both in the
city and the country for because of the
greatness of their empire many things
were brought to them from foreign
countries and the island itself provided
most of what was required by them for
the uses of life in the first place they
dug out of the earth whatever was to be
found there solid as well as fusil and
that which is now only a name and was
then something more than a name or a
Chalco was dug out of the earth in many
parts of the island being more precious
in those days than anything
except gold there was an abundance of
wood for carpenters work and sufficient
maintenance for tame and wild animals
moreover there were a great number of
elephants in the island for as there was
provision for all other sorts of animals
both those which live in lakes and
marshes and rivers and also for those
who live in mountains and on Plains so
there was for the animal which is the
largest and most of a ratios of all also
whatever fragrant things that are now in
the earth where the roots or her Beach
or woods or essences which distill from
fruit and flower grew and thrived in
that land also the fruit which admits of
cultivation both the dry sort which is
given us for nourishment and any other
which we use for food we call them all
by the common name pulse and the fruits
having a hard rind affording drinks and
meats and Entenmann's and good store of
chestnuts and the like which furnish
pleasure and amusement and our fruits
which spoil with keeping and the
pleasant kinds of dessert with which we
console ourselves after dinner when we
are tired of eating all these that
sacred island which then beheld the
light of the Sun brought forth fair and
wondrous in infinite abundance with such
blessings the earth freely furnished
them meanwhile they went on constructing
their temples and palaces and harbours
and docks and they arranged the whole
country in the following manner first of
all they bridged over the zones of sea
which surrounded the ancient metropolis
making a road to and
the royal palace and at the very
beginning they built the palace in the
habitation of the god and their
ancestors which they continued to
ornament in successive generations every
kings are passing the one who went
before him to the utmost of his power
until they made the building a marvel to
behold for size and for beauty and
beginning from the sea they board a
canal of 300 feet in width and 100 feet
in depth and 50 stadia in length which
they carried through to the outermost
zone making a passage from the sea up to
this which became a harbor and leaving
an opening sufficient to enable the
largest vessels to find ingress
moreover they divided at the bridges
these zones of land which parted the
zones of sea leaving room for a single
trireme to pass out of one zone into
another and they covered over the
channels as to leave away underneath for
the ships for the banks were raised
considerably above the water now the
largest of the zones into which a
passage was cut from the sea was three
stadia in breadth and the zone of land
which came next of equal breadth but the
next two zones the one of water the one
of land were two stadia and the one
which surrounded the central island was
a stadium only in width the island in
which the palace was situated had a
diameter of five stadia all this
including the zones and the bridge which
was the sixth part of a stadium in width
they surrounded by a stone wall on every
side placing towers and gates on the
bridges where the sea passed in the
stone which was used in the work they
quarried from underneath the center
island and from underneath the zones on
the outer as well as the inner side one
kind was white another black and a third
red and as they quarried there at the
same time hollowed out double docks
having roofs formed out of the native
rock some of their buildings were simple
but in others they put together
different stones varying the color to
please the eye and to be a natural
source of delight which went round the
outermost zone
they covered with a coating of brass and
the circuit of the next war they coated
with tin and the third which encompassed
the Citadel flashed with the red light
of orichalcum
[Music]
the palaces in the interior of the
citadel constructed on this wise in the
center was a holy temple dedicated to
clay to--and poseidon which remained
inaccessible and was surrounded by an
enclosure of gold this was the spot
where the family of the ten princes
first saw the light and thither the
people annually brought the fruits of
the earth in their season from all the
ten portions to be an offering to each
of the ten here was Poseidon's own
temple which was a stadium in length and
half a stadium in width and of a
proportion at height having a strange
barbaric appearance all the outside of
the temple with the exception of the
pinnacles they covered with silver and
the pinnacles with gold in the interior
of the temple the roof was of ivory
curiously wrought everywhere with gold
and silver and orochon and all the other
parts the walls and the pillars and
floor they coated with orach alchemy in
the temple they placed statues of gold
there was the God himself standing in a
chariot that charioteer of six winged
horses and such a size then he touched
the roof of the building with his head
there were also in the interior of the
temple other images which had been
dedicated by private persons and around
the temple on the outside were placed
statues of gold of all the descendants
of the ten kings and of their wives and
there were many other great offerings of
kings and of private persons coming from
both the city itself and from the
foreign cities over which they held sway
there was an altar to which in size and
workmanship corresponding to this
magnificence and the palaces in like
manner answered to the greatness of the
kingdom and the glory of the temple
leaving the palace and passing out along
the three you came to a wall which began
at the sea and went all round this was
everywhere distant fifty stadia from the
largest zone or harbour and they closed
the hole the ends meeting at the mouth
of the channel which led to the sea
the entire area was densely crowded with
habitations and the canal and the
largest of the harbours were full of
vessels and merchants coming from all
paths who from their numbers kept up a
constant sound of human voices and din
and clatter of all sorts night and day I
described the city and the environs of
the ancient Palace nearly in the world
is so long and now I must endeavour to
represent the nature and arrangement of
the rest of the land the whole country
was said by him to be very lofty and
precipitous on the side of the sea but
the country immediately about and
surrounding the city was a level plane
itself surrounded by mountains which
descended towards the sea it was smooth
and even and of an oblong shape
extending in one direction three
thousand stadia but across the centre
inland it was two thousand stadia this
part of the island looks towards the
south and was sheltered by the north the
surrounding mountains were celebrated
for their number and size and beauty far
beyond any which still exists having in
them also many wealthy villages of
country-folk and rivers and lakes and
meadows supplying food enough for every
animal wild or tame and much wood or
various sorts abundant for each and
every kind of work I will now describe
the plain as it was fashioned by nature
and by the labors of many generations of
kings through long ages it was for the
most part rectangular and oblong and
we're falling out of the straight line
followed the circular ditch the depth
and width and length of the ditch were
incredible and gave the impression that
a work of such extent in addition to so
many others
never have been artificial nevertheless
I must say when I was told it was
excavated to the depth of a hundred feet
and its breadth with a stadium
everywhere it was carried round the hole
of the plane and was ten thousand stadia
in length it received of streams which
came down from the mountains and winding
round the plane and meeting at the city
was there let off into the sea further
inland likewise Street canals a hundred
feet in width were cut from it through
the plain and again let off into the
ditch leading to the sea these canals
were intervals of a hundred stadia and
by them they brought down the world from
the mountains to the city and conveyed
the fruits of the earth in ships cutting
transverse passages from one canal into
another and to the city twice in the
year they gathered the fruits of the
earth in winter having the benefit of
the rains of heaven and in summer the
water which the land supplied by
introducing streams from the canals as
to the population each of the Lots in
the plain had to find a leader for the
men who were fit for military service
and the size of a lot was a square of
ten stadia each way and the total number
of all the Lots was 60,000 and of the
inhabitants of the mountains and the
rest of the country there was also a
vast multitude which was distributed
among the lots and had leaders assigned
to them according to their districts and
villages the leader was required to
furnish for the war the sixth portion of
a war chariot so as to make up a total
of ten thousand chariots also to horses
and riders for them and a pair of
chariot horses without a seat
accompanied by a horseman who could
fight on foot carrying a small shield
and having a charioteer who stood behind
the man-at-arms to guide the two horses
also he was bound to furnish two heavy
armed soldiers to slingers three stone
shooters and three Java
man who were light-armed and for sailors
to make up the compliment of twelve
hundred ships such was the military
order of the Royal City the order of the
other nine governments varied and it
would be wearisome to recount their
several differences as to offices and
honors the following was the arrangement
from the first each of the ten kings in
his own division and in his own City had
the absolute control of the citizens and
in most cases the laws punishing and
slaying whomsoever he would now the
order of precedence among them and their
mutual relations were regulated by the
commands of Poseidon which the law had
handed down they were inscribed by the
first kings on a pillar of orichalcum
which was situated in the middle of the
island at the temple of poseidon whether
the kings were gathered together every
fifth and every sixth year alternately
thus giving equal honour to the odd and
to the even number and when they were
gathered together they consulted about
their common interests and inquired if
anyone had transgressed in anything and
passed judgment and before they passed
judgment they gave their pledges to one
another in this way there were Bulls who
had the range of the Temple of Poseidon
and the ten Kings being left alone in
the temple after they had offered
prayers to the God that they might
capture the victim which was acceptable
to him punted the Bulls without weapons
but with staves and nooses and the bull
which they caught they led up to the
pillar and cut its throat over the top
of it so that the blood fell upon the
sacred inscription now on the pillar
besides the laws there was inscribed an
oath invoking mighty curses on the
disobedient when therefore after slaying
the bull in the accustomed manner they
had burnt its limbs they filled a bowl
of wine
cast in a clot of blood for each of them
the rest of the victim they put in the
fire after having purified the column
all round then they drew from the bowl
in golden cups and pouring a libation on
the fire they swore that they would
judge according to the laws on the
pillar and will punish him who in any
point had already transgressed them and
that for the future they would not if
they could help offend against the
writing on the pillar and would neither
command others nor are they any ruler
who commanded them to act otherwise and
according to the laws of their father
Poseidon this was the prayer which each
of them offered up for himself and for
his descendants at the same time
drinking and dedicating the cup out of
which he drank in the temple of the God
and after they had sucked and satisfied
their needs when darkness came on and
the fire about the sacrifice was cool
all of them put on most beautiful as
your robes and sitting on the ground at
night over the embers of the sacrifice
by which they had sworn and
extinguishing all the fire about the
temple they received and gave judgment
if any of them had an accusation to
bring against anyone and when they had
given judgement at daybreak they wrote
down their sentences on a golden tablet
and dedicated it together with their
robes to be a memorial there were many
special laws affecting the several kings
inscribed about the temples but the most
important was the following they were
not to take up arms against one another
and they were all to come to the rescue
if anyone in any of their cities
attempted to overthrow the royal house
like their ancestors they were to
deliberate in common about war and other
matters giving the supremacy to the
descendants of Atlas and the King was
not to have the power of life and death
over any of his kinsmen unless he had
the assent
of the majority of the ten such was the
vast power which the God settled in the
lost island of Atlantis and this he
afterwards directed against our land for
the following reasons has tradition
tells for many generations as long as
the divine nature lasted in them they
were obedient to the laws and well
affectioned towards the gods who seed
they were they possessed true and in
every way great spirits uniting
gentleness with wisdom in the various
chances of life and in their intercourse
with one another they despised
everything but virtue caring little for
the present state of life and thinking
likely of the possession of gold and
other property which seemed only a
burden to them neither were they
intoxicated by luxury nor did wealth
deprive them of their self-control but
they were sober and saw clearly that all
these goods are increased by virtue and
friendship with one another whereas by
two great regard and respect for them
they are lost and friendship with them
by such reflections and by the
continuance in them of a divine nature
the qualities which we have described
grew and increased among them but when
the divine portion began to fade away
had became diluted too often and too
much with the mortal admixture and the
human nature got the upper hand
they then being unable to bear their
fortune behaved unseemly and to him who
had an eye to see grew visibly the based
for they were losing the fairest of
their precious gifts but to those who
had no eye to see the true happiness
they appeared glorious and blessed at
the very time when they were full of
avarice and unrighteous power
[Music]
Zeus the god of gods who rules according
to law and is able to see such things
perceiving that an honorable race was in
a woeful plight and wanting to inflict
punishment on them that they might be
chastened and improved collected all the
gods into their most holy habitation
which being placed in the center of the
world the holes all created things and
when he had them together he spake as
follows
[Music]
[Music]
you